I'm going to tell you a true story,
but instead of the name
of the protagonist,
think about your favorite artist.
Think about your favorite musician,
and think about your favorite
song by that musician.
Think about them bringing that song
from nothing to something into your ears
and bringing you so much joy.
Now think about your favorite musician
getting sued, and that lawyer saying,
"I represent this group.
I think you heard their song
and then you wrote yours.
You violated their copyright."
And imagine your musician saying,
"No, it's not true.
I don't think I've ever heard that song.
But even if I did,
I certainly wasn't thinking about them
when I made my song."
Imagine the case going to trial
and a judge saying, "I believe you,
I don't think you consciously
copied that group.
But what I think did happen
is you subconsciously copied them.
You violated the copyright,
and you have to pay them a lot of money.”
Think about whether that's fair or just.
This actually happened to George Harrison,
the lead guitarist of The Beatles,
and the group was The Chiffons,
who's had a song
"He's so fine, oh so fine."
And George Harrison had a song,
"My sweet Lord, oh, sweet Lord."
But what neither George Harrison
nor The Chiffons nor the judge, really,
nor anybody else had considered,
is maybe since the beginning of time,
the number of melodies
is remarkably finite.
Maybe there are only so many
melodies in this world.
And The Chiffons,
when they picked their melody,
plucked it from that already existing
finite melodic data set.
And George Harrison happened
to have plucked the same melody
from that same finite melodic data set.
This is a different way
of thinking about music
in a way that judges and lawyers
nor musicians have thought about.
Because when those groups
have thought about musicians,
they think about them drawing
from their own creative wellspring,
bringing from nothing,
something into the world.
They have a blank page
upon which they can put their creativity.
That's actually not true.
As George Harrison realized,
you have to avoid every song
that's ever been written,
because if you don't, you get sued.
If you're lucky, you pluck
one of those already existing melodies
that hasn't been taken.
If you're unlucky, you pluck a melody
that's already been taken.
Whether you've heard that song or not,
maybe you've never heard it before.
If that happens, if you're lucky,
you have a co-songwriter
or somebody who says,
that new song sounds a lot
like that old song.
And you change it before
it goes out the door.
Now, if you're unlucky,
you don't have somebody telling you that,
you release it out in the world,
the group hears your song and they sue you
for a song maybe that you've never
heard before in your life.
You've just stepped on a melodic landmine.
The thing is, this is the world
before my colleague, Noah Rubin, and I
have started our project.
The world now looks like this.
We filled in every melody
that's ever existed and ever can exist.
Every step is going to be
a melodic landmine.
And ironically, this is actually
trying to help songwriters.
Let me tell you how.
I'm a lawyer.
I've been a lawyer since 2002.
I've litigated copyright cases,
I've taught law school copyright cases.
I'm also a musician.
I have a bachelor’s degree
in music, I’m a performer,
I'm a recording artist,
and I also produce records.
I'm also a technologist.
I've been coding since 1985,
for the web since '95.
I’ve done cybersecurity,
and I also currently design software.
So that puts me right
in the middle of a Venn diagram
that gives me a few insights
that if I were in any one of those areas
I might not have had.
And my colleague Noah Rubin,
in addition to being one of the smartest
people I've ever known,
he's also a musician,
and he's also one of the most
brilliant programmers I've known.
And between our work,
we came to a realization
that you may have had saying,
"You know that new song?
It sounds a lot like this other old song."
And there's a reason for that.
We've discovered that there
is only so many melodies,
there are only so many notes
that can be arranged in so many ways.
And that's different than visual art,
where they're an infinite number
of brushstrokes, colors and subjects
that to accidentally do them
is very difficult.
Similarly with language,
the English language
has 117,000 words in it,
so the odds of accidentally writing
the same paragraph are next to zero.
In contrast,
music doesn't have 117,000 words.
Music has eight notes.
Do, Re, Mi, Fa, Sol, La, Ti, Do.
One two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
And every popular melody
that's ever existed and ever can exist
is those eight notes.
Now, it's remarkably small.
I worked in cybersecurity,
and I know if I wanted to attack
your password and hack your password,
one way to do it is to use a computer
to really quickly say aaaa. No?
Aab, aac,
And to keep running
until it hits your password.
That's called brute-forcing a password.
So I thought, what if you could
brute force melodies?
What if you could say,
Do-Do-Do-Do, Do-Do-Do-Re,
Do-Do-Do-Mi.
And then exhaust every melody
that's ever been.
And the way the computers
read music is called MIDI.
And in MIDI it looks like this
Do-Do-Do-Do, Do-Do-Do-Re.
So I approached my colleague Noah,
I said, Noah, can you write an algorithm
to be able to march through
every melody that's ever existed
and ever can exist?
He said, "Yeah, I could do that."
So at a rate of 300,000
melodies per second,
he wrote a program to write to disk
every melody that's ever existed
and ever can exist.
And in my hand right now
is every melody that's ever existed
and ever can exist.
And the thing is, to be copyrighted,
you don't have to do anything formal.
As soon as it's written to a fixed,
tangible medium, this hard drive,
it's copyrighted automatically.
Now, this leaves copyright law
with a very interesting question,
because you think about the world before
and songwriters had to avoid every song
that's ever been written, in red.
Noah and I have exhausted
the entire melodic copyright.
So if you superimpose the songs
that have been written, in red,
with the songs that haven't
yet been written,
you have an interesting question:
Have we infringed every melody
that's ever been?
And in the future, every songwriter
that writes in the green spots,
have they infringed us?
Now, you might think at this point,
are you some sort of copyright troll
that's trying to take over the world?
And I would say, no, absolutely not.
In fact, the opposite is true.
Noah and I are songwriters ourselves.
We want to make the world
better for songwriters.
So what we've done
is we're taking everything
and putting it in the public domain.
We're trying to keep space
open for songwriters
to be able to make music.
And we're not focused on the lyrics,
we're not focused on recording,
we're focused on melodies.
And the thing is, we're running out
of melodies that we can use.
The copyright system is broken
and it needs updating.
Some of the insights
that we've received as part of our work
is that melodies to a computer
are just numbers
because those melodies have existed
since the beginning of time,
and we're only just discovering them.
So the melody Do-Re-Mi-Re-Do
to a computer is literally 1-2-3-2-1.
So really the number 1-2-3-2-1
is just a number.
It's just math that's been existing
since the beginning of time.
And under the copyright laws,
numbers are facts.
And under copyright law,
facts either have thin copyright,
almost no copyright
or no copyright at all.
So maybe if these numbers have existed
since the beginning of time
where we're just plucking them out,
maybe melodies are just math,
which is just facts,
which maybe are not copyrightable.
Maybe if somebody's suing
over a melody alone,
not lyrics, not recordings,
but just the melody alone,
maybe those cases go away.
Maybe they get dismissed.
Now you might say,
well, what constitutes a melody?
And we were initially going to take
the entire piano keyboard
and be able to do the entire keyboard.
But we thought,
let's focus on the vocal range,
which is actually two octaves.
And then we thought, no, actually
we're thinking about pop music,
which is the only thing that makes money
that people sue over.
So we looked at musicologists,
and they have debated what is a motif,
a short melody versus a longer melody.
And we landed with 12 notes.
And then we superimposed that number
with songs that have either been litigated
or threatened to be litigated.
For example, The Chiffons
had “He’s so fine, oh so fine.”
Versus “My sweet Lord, Oh, sweet Lord.”
Eight notes.
Doo doo doo doo doo doo doo.
(Laughter)
Doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo.
That's so close.
(Laughter)
"Oh, I won't back down.
No, I won't back down."
Versus “Won’t you stay with me
'cause you're all I need."
Ten notes.
Doo doo doo doo, doo doo doo doo.
Versus Katy Perry's
Doo doo doo doo, doo doo doo, doo.
Last two notes are different.
The jury didn't care, 2.8 million dollars.
Audience: Ooh.
DR: So every song within that is within
our parameters of eight notes up,
major and minor, 12 notes across.
So what you see in red
is every popular melody
that's ever existed and ever can exist.
So all Noah and I had to do is to be able
to exhaust that remarkably finite,
remarkably small data set.
There aren't that many of them.
Eight up, 12 across.
You might say, Damien, songs are more
than just melodies, there's chords too.
And I would totally agree with you
because it turns out
that that's even easier.
In 2017, Peter Burkimsher
exhausted every chord.
You can download it today in GitHub.
We're instead focused not on lyrics,
not on recordings,
we're focused on melodies.
And the thing is, we're running out
because the song isn't just
a single melody,
but there are many parts to a song,
and each part of that song can have
many motifs and melodies within it.
So each song can have
up to ten melodies and motifs.
So SoundCloud, which is a way
that musicians can upload to this website
and distribute their work,
SoundCloud currently
has 200 million songs,
and the number of open spaces
is shrinking exponentially.
Because every basement musician
is recording, and they’re recording
and they’re uploading it
to YouTube, to Spotify
and to SoundCloud.
And they are exhausting
the entire mathematical data set.
They're exhausting the open spaces.
until there are not going
to be any more left.
What Noah and I have done is we're trying
to preserve those spots that are left.
We're trying to be able
to take those green spots,
put them in the public domain
so that other people
can be able to make them.
Because we're running out.
The thing is we're just getting started
because if you go to our website,
AllTheMusic.info, you can not only
download all the music we've made,
which is a lot,
you can also download
the program that we used,
and we're giving away the code for free
so you can expand upon our work.
Something I didn't tell you
is that those eight notes that we did,
as we speak right now,
we've expanded that to 12 notes.
So instead of just the white notes,
now we've got the black notes, too.
So we're covering jazz, classical music,
and we think it's only a matter of time
before somebody is going to expand that
to do the entire piano keyboard
and take our 12 notes
and expand it to 100
with every rhythmic variation
and every chordal variation
till our remarkably finite mathematical
data set gets further exhausted.
This is going to happen.
And the thing is,
how is the law going to respond?
Because the thing is, we're not focused
on somebody copying
a previous person's melody.
We're focused instead on somebody
accidentally copying a song
that they either have heard
and forgotten about
or have never heard before in their lives.
And the chance of landing
in an open spot is remarkably small,
and it's shrinking every day.
And the thing is,
the odds of you as a songwriter
getting sued are remarkably high.
And if you get sued,
you're going want to think about
what a judge or a jury
is going to think about,
and they are going to think
about two questions.
The first question is:
Is that previous songwriter’s
copyright valid?
Do they even have a copyright
in that previous song?
Second question is:
Did you infringe their copyright?
So to the first question,
maybe the answer to that is no,
because if they're suing
just over the melody,
maybe that melody's existed
since the beginning of time.
Maybe there are only so many notes
that are math, that are not copyrightable.
To the second question did you infringe,
there are two sub questions.
The first question is: Did you access,
did you hear that previous song?
And if so, are those two songs
substantially similar?
Now the first question: Did you access
or hear that previous song?
That's got a lot of problems,
it's really problematic.
And the reason for that
is there are only a few cases
where access is crystal clear.
For example, John Fogerty was alleged
to have infringed John Fogerty
when he was part of Creedence.
So clearly John Fogerty
had access to John Fogerty songs.
On the opposite end
of the spectrum, on no access,
what if a baby were to sing
into their toy?
And again, as soon
as the toy recorder happens,
it's copyrighted automatically,
it's a fixed, tangible medium.
So if a baby starts singing
Da da da da da, da da da da da da.
And a year later, Taylor Swift sings,
"I stay up too late.
Got nothing in my brain."
Clearly, Taylor Swift
has not infringed that baby
because Taylor Swift has not heard
that baby's recording, OK?
Clear case of no access.
But the thing is, almost none
of the cases are that clear.
What if there's a question mark
as to whether the second person
heard it or not?
Maybe they heard it, maybe they didn't.
Maybe they heard it and forgot it.
Maybe they subconsciously infringed.
These are all what the law
calls fact questions.
And the thing is, almost every copyright
case that comes out is a fact question.
Almost never is it as clear
as John Fogerty
or as clear as Taylor Swift.
Almost every case is that middle section,
that fact question.
And the hard part about fact questions
is they're notoriously hard to resolve
at an early stage in the case,
because when you think
about a life span of a lawsuit,
it starts out as a cease
and desist letter.
You need to pay me or I'll sue you.
It goes forward
and it's going to take years.
And the thing about fact questions,
they don't get resolved
until the end of that process.
That's what happened to George Harrison.
After trial, the judge said,
"I think you subconsciously infringed."
So if you're a songwriter
who's never heard a melody before,
but you are approached by somebody
saying you stole their song,
what are you going to do?
Sam Smith was approached by Tom Petty.
Tom Petty said, “My song ‘Won’t Back Down’
sounds like your ‘Stay with Me.’”
Sam Smith reportedly responded,
"Hey, man, I've never heard
your song before.
That was written before I was born."
But if I was in Sam Smith’s position,
I would look at this long road ahead of me
and the prospect at the end
of a judge saying, you know,
"I think you subliminally infringed."
So what are you going to do?
It's not surprising that Sam Smith
made Tom Petty a co-songwriter,
giving Tom Petty a lot
of his songwriting royalties.
Radiohead had a song,
"And I'm a creep. I'm a weirdo."
The Hollies said,
"Hey, that sounds like our song."
They made them co-songwriters
Lana Del Rey ironically,
had a song that sounds like "Creep."
Offered to make them
co-songwriters, reportedly.
Katy Perry had a song that she testified
and all of her co-songwriters testified,
"I have never heard that previous
song before in my life"
and the other side didn't dispute it.
They say, "We have no evidence
that they actually heard the song,
but we did have three-point-some
million YouTube views,
so they must have heard it."
A jury agreed with them and Katy Perry
was on the hook for 2.8 million dollars.
Now, if you are an accused songwriter
who's never heard the song before,
that is an untenable position.
How are you going to avoid
getting shaken down
for something that you may
have never heard?
Shouldn't there be an easier way?
Shouldn't there be a way
that early on in that process
for a judge or a lawyer to be able to have
an early evidentiary hearing to say
maybe melodies are math, which are facts
which are not copyrightable.
Or maybe there's no evidence
showing that this later person
has heard the earlier person's song.
Maybe the idea of subconscious
infringement goes by.
Now if you are a songwriter,
you should really care about this
because each day
you are walking in a minefield
that you didn't even know was there.
You’re trying to avoid every song,
whether you’ve heard that song or not.
And Noah and I, we're trying
to preserve those open spaces
so that you can be able to make
the music in the public domain
in a way that you've always thought it.
The question is not: “Have I made
this new song or not?”
Because no song is new.
Noah and I have exhausted the data set.
The real question:
"Is my song a green song,
or is my song a red song?"
Or perhaps the real question is:
Should you have the blank page
that everybody thinks is there
in the first place?
If you're a judge or a lawyer,
think about having an early
evidentiary hearing
to be able to take the evidenciary
burden from the defendant
to prove negative
that they've never heard that song
and bring it back to the plaintiff
where it belongs,
that they have to prove
that the other side heard the song.
And they have to prove that that melody
is more than just a fact.
And if you are a song lover,
you should really care about this
because the current state
has a chilling effect on songwriters.
Something that I haven't told you
is that George Harrison, after the trial,
he stopped writing music for a while.
He told "Rolling Stone"
that, after the trial,
"It's hard to start writing again
because every song I hear
sounds like something else."
There's a reason for that, George.
Because there are only so many notes.
There are only so many melodies.
And the open spaces
are running out exponentially.
Now, ironically, Noah and I
have made all the melodies
and put them into the public domain
in an effort to try to give
songwriters more freedom,
to be able to make more and more music
and less fear of accidentally stepping
on musical landmines.
Noah and I have made all the music
to be able to allow future songwriters
to make all of their music.
Thank you.
(Applause)